CONTINUE TO MELT DOWN OF OUR
PRESIDENT TRUMP CELEBRATING THE
FOURTH OF JULY AT MOUNT RUSHMORE
THIS WEEKEND, THE DNC, THEY ARE
EVEN FINDING MORE WAYS TO
COMPLETELY EMBARRASS THEMSELVES
AND THIS WILL BE ON THE BALLOT
IN 126 DAYS, IN A NOW DELETED
TWEET THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
"GLORIFYING WHITE SUPREMACY BY
GOING TO THE ICONIC LANDMARKS TO
CELEBRATE OUR NATION’S
INDEPENDENCE.
JOINING US NOW FOR A REACTION,
SOUTH DAKOTA GOVERNOR KRISTI
NOEM.
GOVERNOR, I DON’T REALLY KNOW
WHAT TO SAY, I GUESS COMRADE
de BLASIO, THEY MAY BE IN FAVOR
OF SANDBLASTING MOUNT RUSHMORE,
I GUESS OTHER DEMOCRATS MIGHT DO
THAT, I’VE ACTUALLY BEEN THERE,
MY KIDS HAVE PLAYED TENNIS
TOURNAMENTS IN YOUR STATE AND I
THINK IT WAS ONE OF THE MOST
SPECTACULAR THINGS I’VE EVER
SEEN IN MY LIFE.
A WORK OF ART, INCREDIBLE
MAGNITUDE ABOUT PEOPLE THAT WERE
NOT PERFECT BUT CREATED
DOCUMENTS THAT ALLOW AMERICA TO
RIGHT WRONGS, CORRECT INJUSTICES
AND ALSO BECOME A MORE PERFECT
UNION WHICH HISTORY HAS PROVEN
THEM RIGHT, WE GET BETTER WHEN
WE TRY.
>> YOU SAID THAT YOU ARE LOOKING
FOR A NEW HOME.
AND I WOULD THINK OF NO BETTER
PLACE THAN THE STATE OF
SOUTH DAKOTA WHERE WE STILL LOVE
FREEDOM AND LIBERTIES AND WHERE
WE CELEBRATE AMERICA’S
INDEPENDENCE AND RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS NATIONAL
MONUMENT.
WE ARE GOING TO BE HAVING AN
EVENT WHERE WE WILL TALK ABOUT
THE PRINCIPLES AND THE VALUES
THAT THIS COUNTRY WAS FOUNDED
ON, WE WILL TALK ABOUT OUR
HISTORY, THE LESSONS IT WILL
TEACH US AND I’M HOPING THAT
EVERYBODY WILL RECOGNIZE THAT
NOW IS A TIME NOT TO DIVIDE OUR
COUNTRY BUT TO UNIFY IT AND TO
HEAL AND TALK ABOUT WHAT REALLY
IS IMPORTANT SO WE CAN MAKE WISE
DECISIONS IN THE FUTURE.
>> Sean: GOVERNOR, I WOULD
HONESTLY LOVE TO LIVE IN
SOUTH DAKOTA.
I’D LOVE TO LIVE ANYWHERE IN LE
NEW YORK.
IT IS A BEAUTIFUL STATE WITH
GREAT AMERICANS, THEY WORK HARD,
THEY ARE INDEPENDENT, THEY PAY
THEIR TAXES, THEY OBEY THE LAWS
AND WE NOT SEE THE MADNESS WE
SEE IN NEW YORK AND NEW JERSEY
AND THAT IDIOT GOVERNOR IN
MICHIGAN AND PENNSYLVANIA, DID
YOU SEND COVID-19 PATIENCE INTO
NURSING HOMES DURING THE HEIGHT
OF COVID?
I DON’T THINK YOU DID.
>> WE DID NOT.
IN FACT, WE HAVE THE LOWEST
HOSPITALIZATION RATE THAT WE’VE
HAD IN MONTHS, WE ARE DOING A
GREAT JOB IN SOUTH DAKOTA AND
THAT’S BECAUSE I ASKED THE FOLKS
HERE TO PRACTICE PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY, TO MAKE THE BEST
DECISIONS FOR THEMSELVES, FOR
THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR
BUSINESSES AND THEY
OVERWHELMINGLY DID THAT, I TOLD
THEM I TRUSTED THEM AND THEY
MADE WIDE DECISIONS AND WE ARE
DOING VERY WELL.
YOU TALKED ABOUT SOUTH DAKOTA
AND OUR BUSINESS ENVIRONMENT, WE
ARE THE LOWEST TAX STATE IN THE
NATION, THE LOWEST REGULATED
STATE IN THE NATION, WE HAVE
PEOPLE EVERY DAY CALLING US
ASKING, HOW CAN I MOVE THERE,
HOW CAN I MOVE MY BUSINESS TO
SOUTH DAKOTA BECAUSE I THINK THE
LAST SEVERAL MONTHS HAVE SHOWN
THE IMPORTANCE OF HAVING LEADERS
AND PEOPLE IN A STATE THAT
RECOGNIZE THE FOUNDING FATHERS
VISION FOR THIS COUNTRY AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE CONSTITUTION
AND HOW THAT GIVES US THE CHANCE
TO STAND ON THOSE FOUNDING
VALUES EVERY SINGLE DAY TO RUN
OUR LIVES.
>> Sean: I GOT TO GIVE YOU A
LOT OF CREDIT, YOU NEVER SHUT
DOWN YOUR STATE AND WHEN YOU HAD
A HOT SPOT WITH THE MEAT-PACKING
INDUSTRY, WHICH ALSO HAPPENED IN
TWO OTHER STATES INCLUDING IOWA,
YOU JUMPED ALL OVER IT AND YOU
ARE ABLE TO LITERALLY MITIGATE
IT VERY QUICKLY AND SAVE LIVES,
YOU DESERVE A LOT OF CREDIT FOR
THAT BECAUSE WE CAN LEARN IN
OTHER STATES HOW TO DO IT AS IT
POPS UP.
I WISH I COULD BE THERE THE
3RD OF JULY, I TRIED TO MOVE
THINGS AROUND BECAUSE I ACTUALLY
WANT TO SEE IT.
UNFORTUNATELY I COULDN’T BUT I
WILL BE IN SOUTH DAKOTA